on avait plusieurs détaillants ont fermé
leurs portes lors des derniers mois l'un
des fleurons de ce secteur aldo s'est
placée à l'abri de ses créanciers en mai
dernier
traînant une dette de plus de 470
millions de dollars ait eu des mises à
pied au siège social la moitié également
des magasins qui ont dû être fermées et
signe de cette cure minceur elle doit
quitter son majestueux siège social de
montréal pour un endroit qui est plus
petit et moins dispendieux et pour
parler des défis l'entreprise et des
détaillants en général j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir le président directeur
général d'ald au david bensadoun bonjour
monsieur bensadoun merci d'être avec
nous je voulais seulement dire un mot
sur le siège social alors je suis déjà
allée votre papa aldo bensadoun le
fondateur du groupe avait même planté un
olivier dans l'agora qui rappelle dans
les obligés d origine marocaine
c'est quoi le sentiment lorsqu'on doit
quitter un endroit comme celui-ci qu'il
le fruit ni plus ni moins de vols à bord
premièrement il faut dire que l'olivier
viens avec nous on a déplacé étaient
présents pour le chanter oui on était
impliqué pour l'enlever et s'y met à
l'abri dans une serre et ça va être un
nouveau siège social
bientôt vous allez trouver un endroit
collectivement pour l'olivier est un peu
le symbole j'ai l'impression de ce siège
social
la résilience russie de cet arbre là là
voilà exactement c'est ça donc vos
origines ont parlé des difficultés vos
difficultés
ce sont les difficultés d'autres
détaillants on a vu ça chez simone on
august chez reitmans également votre
secteur avait connu des changements qui
sont profondes avec la pandémie s'est
coincé c'est la goutte de trop
la situation est complètement faux si
quelqu'un ait pu nous parler en février
ils ont dit bachar à pendage dans les
centres d'achat va descendre de 70%
personnes d'aller au bureau pendant
quatre mois les genres et 10e crise
vous n'auriez pas pu le croire alors là
on se trouve dans une situation reste
tout change mais non les champs les
choses changent pour nos employés
les gens sont contents à la maison quand
on parle avec eux ils disent qu'en peut
retourner au bureau je veux travailler
deux ou trois jours par semaine je veux
pas travailler cinq jours par semaine au
bureau alors ils trouvent que la
flexibilité que ça leur donne est très
important et avec tout ça on réalise
qu'on a on avait trop d'espacés
un point de vue non lé travail
on avait trop d'espacés pour ce beau
changer d'endroit donc pour laisser
davantage de gens à télétravailler
exactement un destin à cause du
télétravail on a besoin de moins
d'essence
à cause d'eux quand on a 19 pour le
futur et le résultat c'est un bureau
chef qui va apprendre deux tiers de
l'espace qu'on avait avant donc il n'est
encore une fois des coûts également
monsieur bensadoun a non les coups ça
réduit par 75%
voilà il vous comme pour nous quand on
est en période de déstructuration il
faut prendre ça au sérieux
il faut libérer le cash pour pouvoir
investir dans la marque et dans nos deux
oreilles et et on va voir un duo qui va
être fonctionnel qui aura confortable
qui va être bien pour nos employés mais
moins grand et moins une gros problème
le pour al d'où le fait que plusieurs de
vos boutiques penser qu'ils étaient
situés dans les centres commerciaux vous
avez parlé donc la baisse drastique
l'achalandage mais aussi aussi d'aller
dans les centres villes
alors qu'ils ont été durement touché
durant la pandémie ne laissant ça dépend
quelle ville il ya des locales dans les
centres villes qui marche c'est bien
parce qu'ils ont là sur l'extérieur gay
souvent les magasins indépendants ils
peuvent bien informée c'est plus dans
les centres commerciaux est ce que c'est
très difficile
il ya beaucoup beaucoup moins
d'achalandage et les gens les magazines
en ligne et sont très contentes
change complètement la clef de la
rentabilité finalement ça passe
essentiellement logo beaucoup on
pourrait dire dans les ventes en ligne
actuellement le pôle et détaillants
comme vous exactement
alors vous travailler là-dessus
davantage actuellement on était bien
préparés pour la vente en ligne on a
toujours eu un plateforme qui était à
qu'ils étaient costauds qui était prêt
pour recevoir beaucoup plus de
l'achalandage et notre système
d'approvisionnement est très flexible on
peut approvisionner des magasins ou des
centre des discussions alors c'est
réflexive et ça nous permet de bien en
compte les besoins de nos clients
mais il faut dire que concours ouvert à
tous les magasins vont quand même être
importants ils vont être au centre de
l'expérience si les gens veulent avoir
le feeling de la marque voir et toucher
le produit nous mêmes un plaisir de deux
magasins pour des des chaussures mode on
pense que les magasins vont rester très
important mais on a besoin de moins de
magasins coop des magasins plus petits
et on devrait payer moins de loyers pour
ces magasins excuses au fait mal
également j'avais lu ça dans un article
c'est un changement de la mode
c'est ce que vous disiez les gens
veulent maintenant des souliers qui sont
plus décontractés alors aldo avait pris
quoi un retard dans ce secteur de la
mode
on a toujours vendu des styles
décontractés on a toujours vendu des
styles afflige euros fiona comment dire
non mais c'est certain que ça augmente
énormément je connais pas enfin qui a
porté des talons hauts dans le dernier
droit moi mais je pense qu envoie un
vaccin
et quant à ce après le cover
on va voir tout le monde va vouloir et
le clé pour nous c'est vraiment devant
toutes les catégories mode
alors si les gens veulent défendre le
décontracté en la cie veulent des shows
sommes plus à pied on a ouais c'est sûr
qu'un télétravail le tableau est moins
populaire je pourrais vous dire monsieur
ben sadoun ça c'est sûr et certain
avec la crise que nous traversons
actuellement votre père votre père aldo
et qu'est-ce qui vous dis là qu'est ce
qui vous glisse à l'oreille le matin
lorsqu'il vous parle il est formidable
c'est une inspiration pour nous tous il
a je vais pas dire son âge mais on va
dire clé qui l'a mis à l'énergie comme
quelqu un dans les 50 n y trouve ça
vraiment une chance de re bâtir la
compagnie est d'être bien préparé pour
le futur maintenant il
il faut dire que ils passent autant de
temps avec notre designer qu'avant alors
certes à science a toujours été le
produit et il reste impliqué avec nos
équipes
tout va bien allez vous êtes protégé de
vos créanciers dernier à question qu'est
ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter qu'elle
nous revienne encore plus fort c'est
certain qu'on revient plus fort on va
être plus léger on va être plus flexible
on va avoir moins de coûts fixes on va
mieux préparés pour la réalité
en orange on y colle et ça va bien aller
c'est tout comme le fameux slogan david
ben fadhloun un grand plaisir merci
beaucoup merci bien au revoir